Poehler is the Netflix adaptation of the
action while graphic novel of the same
name this recent release to the platform
has a lot to unpack from it and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the film and its ending there will
of course be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything about
the movie and I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to we follow Duncan vislar the
world's top assassin who has been forced
into a reluctant retirement due to his
age bit slur also known as the black
Kaiser seems to be settling into this
new lifestyle however after his former
employee Damocles mocks him as a
liability he finds himself having to
fight for his survival against a new
generation of trained killers in the
first of many John wick comparisons
bezler gets a dog but unlike wick he is
the one who kills it when he
accidentally should set due to a
nightmare brought on by his PTSD this
kind of sets the tone for the movie
which is sort of a cross between smokin
aces and lucky number Slevin due to his
isolation and solitude vizla is tempted
with another job which involves
assassinating a high-value target mr.
blue played by Matt Lucas in one of the
worst weeks of his career has organized
this hit himself in order to put bass
lab a kin there crosshairs
so he can save himself having to pay
vislar a retirement fee and allowing
their pension to return to the company
this the carries out the hit on the
target and it will pretty much leave any
guy grabbing their balls in pain at this
location though Kaiser discovers that
someone has set him up and returns to
his home where he is introduced to
Camille and played by Vanessa Hudgens
like this let Camille is a loner and the
two characters find some common ground
with one of them in the meantime at the
hired assassins on business tail are
slowly moving through all of the
properties he owns killing the tenants
and tracking him down this is when the
movie goes crazy with over-the-top
violence gore teaching kids how to use
knives french fries and the recounting
of kaisers past
he buys Vanessa a gun and takes it up to
her Lodge which I'm pretty sure is that
one that was in The Handmaid's Tale bit
of trivia for you there guys anyway he
tries to
teacher how to shoot but she can't bring
herself to do it and Camille recounts
the time that she was raped at work by a
colleague which is why she has removed
herself from society
she also confesses that she would love
to get revenge on her rapist and murder
him something which ties into the ending
by this point booth assassins have
tracked down Bislett and sending their
best female to have sex with him as
Lodge make sure your parents are out of
the room for that scene kids anyway
Bislett is of course aware of this being
the creepy old man with the moustache
that years and he stops their ambush
probably still with a boner
don't worry biz we know it was cold
outside anyway he takes down the
assassins and discovers that Camille is
missing then learns about the pension
plans and is captured by one of glutes
assassins his lair is chained up
tortured for days and loses his eye in
what ends up being like a scene from
Metal Gear Solid Snake Eater vizla
manages to escape however by pulling out
a knife shot that was embedded in him
and goes into Solid Snake mode even
further
taking down blitz gods and making a
Wolverine escape from alkali lake look
like a walk in the park as blue still
has Camille abyss la offers a trade for
himself in exchange for her life but
this doesn't go down too well business
up with a former contact and pretty much
get his own high-tech army of guns and
ammo with some amazing hand cannons that
look like they were ripped straight out
of thor ragnarok there's mows down most
of the people that get in his way on his
journey to big bad bald bad-boy blue to
who he beheads in a hilarious scene
vislar returns home with Camille which
is when he discovers an orgy of evidence
that reveals that Camille's rape story
was in fact a lie and that he was
actually the assassin that murdered her
entire family in front of her as a child
something that we saw in a flashback
Camille reveals that she's been tracking
him down for her entire life as she
pulls a gun on the character and
confesses how much he has become her
obsession this tries to reason with her
that it was a mistake due to bad
information and out of guilt he has been
donating amounts to a charity that has
helped Camille through the years
Camille is unable to kill vizla though
and the two agreed to track down the man
who originally put out the hit
your father together which brings the
movie to a close so what are your
thoughts on polar did you enjoy it and
do you feel that lived up to the hype
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video please like it and make
sure you check out my review on the film
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]